hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm chief UN weapons inspector Dave
Rubin
and I've got Liane tweed and hot off
Hannity not a lot of people go from
vanity to the Reuben report too and I've
got Jimmy Dore hot off the Jimmy Dore
show which people do sometimes do the
Jimmy Dore show then come here yes okay
all right let's start with the Middle
East crisis of the week it was just a
week ago that we were all talking about
Egypt I guess that thing resolved itself
so that was pretty good we are on to
Syria it looks like we're gonna have a
war possibly later this afternoon
possibly tomorrow we shall see I don't
want to make light of it though a
hundred thousand people have died in
conventional warfare and then suddenly
the chemicals have started to be being
used this week it looked like about a
thousand people but they've been used a
couple of times before that and now
there's evidence of it and let's listen
to the human tree John Kerry discussing
what happened the indiscriminate
slaughter of civilians the killing of
women and children and innocent
bystanders by chemical weapons is a
moral obscenity by any standard it is
inexcusable and despite the excuses and
equivocations that some have
manufactured it is undeniable alright
that's pretty much the most emotional
I've ever seen John Kerry I don't quite
understand the distinction somehow it's
okay if a hundred thousand people die by
bombs and bullets but if they coughed
before they die now were suddenly very
upset so let's just start with that is
the red line I mean Obama said the red
line thing so he's sort of painted
himself into a corner here is the red
line thing because of chemical weapons
does it has that now forced our hand
here and we have to do something well I
think Obama said it last year that if
they use chemical weapons that is that
is a hard line for the United States and
probably the rest of the world or the
Western world but I think it's very
interesting we talked about this earlier
like he said it's okay to slaughter and
kill women and children with bombs and
bullets and you know attacks and sniper
bullets and stuff like that but God
forbid they drop one of those bombs a
little bit of gas on it and kill people
in the middle of the night and then
suddenly now we're gonna do something
two and a half years in
to this Civil War so it's very difficult
I was watching some news last night I
was watching some old generals and some
special operators some strategy you know
military strategists and they're like so
we're basically just gonna you know
maybe throw some tomahawk missiles in
there teach them a lesson don't do you
know don't drop chemical bombs on your
people again and then get loud and not
really do anything don't put boots on I
mean obviously we probably have
operatives in there and CIA people and
stuff but as far as like and we're
announcing it to the world I don't know
I just don't I don't
I'd rather probably not do anything and
let them have their civil war because
what good is it gonna do for the United
States or any of the other countries
around well you guys we got two about
five of the questions that I want to get
to but I know let's start though with
with just the the distinction between
which way people can die do you find it
more okay for a hundred thousand people
to die via conventional warfare than
chemical warfare and again I'm not
diminishing the exact due date because
I'm an American I mean like why can't
the you know only a depraved animal
would use chemical weapons to kill
someone why can't they use a nice
Christian depleted uranium to bomb like
we use here how about what they drop one
of those bombs we dropped on Japan that
doesn't kill women and children whatever
they do want to why don't they do that
because we're so much better it's so
good to see John Kerry gets so pissed
off about indiscriminate killing because
you know he served in Vietnam and if
anybody knows about indiscriminate
killing its John Kerry so this
self-righteous [ __ ] about chemical
weapons like because what he's really
saying is if you're gonna kill someone
you better blow their [ __ ] head off
that's what he's saying because if I go
when I see a body without blood on it
I'm upset at you and that's literally
what he said during that press
conference he's actually saying if you
would have just destroyed the whole city
that you dropped the chemical Epis in
and then we wouldn't have evidence of it
we would have been okay there you see
bodies laying there without blood on
them yeah and that upsets him and yes
yeah so this is all great what this is
is that we've been committing so many
war crimes for so long and we've been
doing so many horrible things that we
have to go look we're not horrible
because we're upset about this right
because we're doing drone strikes right
now in Yemen and in other parts of the
Middle East and innocent people are
being killed and we could put that
taps yeah and you know what that is
right I do when they come back again
yeah so that but that's a whole separate
issue so alright so let's talk about so
it looks like we're going to war but
yeah we're not gonna call it war because
we're gonna do what we did in Libya it
was like they called it when they was an
Xbox Kinect military action is a strike
from a couple boats off the shore and
they'll go back out into the water right
so Obama who has always said you know
you have to have congressional
authorization and we should go through
the UN well it doesn't look like we're
gonna do it but Barak guess what your
buddy Joe Biden said about George W Bush
doing that the president award in red
without congressional approval I will
make it my business to impatient
okay so there you have it that's Biden
in 2007 talking about George W Bush but
now he's the VP of President Obama who's
about to do the exact same thing
hypocrisy what I mean I have a hard time
taking Biden seriously on anything he
says so now that he's piping in along
with John Kerry yeah I would like it to
go to Congress because I think the the
Congress who are supposed to represent
the people which are us you would hope
that they'd have at least a say and if
we are going to I hope not start a war
but if we are going to attack another
country and and to do what they say is
gonna happen today or tomorrow then you
know I I think we should go to Congress
yeah do you make any distinction between
just lobbing a couple Rockets so that's
not war versus you know something bigger
that then would be war I mean I'm pretty
sure if Canada lobbed a rocket into the
United States we would consider that an
act of war well the al Qaeda didn't even
use Rockets when we considered it an act
of war they just hijacked a couple of
planes so yes of course you know of
course it's the squiggly line of
whatever the [ __ ] we want it to be
whenever we feel like it whatever serves
us right but shouldn't we all be
seriously upset with Obama right now
because he's the one that has pushed
this idea of everything has to go
through the UN which now it's very clear
that's not gonna happen
and everything has to go through
Congress you know you know a lot of
things that he's just pushed through
himself you know up until this point so
it doesn't surprise me that he's doing
that now yeah so final question on this
is this actually Obama's fault because
of the red line thing not that what the
killing is not his fault there but
because he really did box us into a
corner where he said this is not send
off the bombs he could not order the
Tomahawk missile shipped yeah I mean
listen I don't want to go to war I don't
think we should be doing anything more
fun what can he not he said oh if we use
chemical weapons what would what would
you think of Obama then would you think
he's a weak president because he said
I'm gonna send we're gonna do something
of chemical weapons well I think that's
thinking I think that's the thinking in
Washington that cetera
and you crossed it and now if he doesn't
do anything the credibility of the
administration well that's that legit
he's got credibility issues anyways
what's the thing about those Peace
Prizes Dave
nobody ever tries to win a second one
perfect perfect ending to this and yeah
Obama got the Nobel Peace Prize before
he was president this is now gonna be
his second war without going to Congress
floor okay
all right let's talk about the Internet
Huffington Post which is like The Drudge
Report for the other guys they are
banning anonymous comments CEO Arianna
Huffington had this to say trolls have
become more and more aggressive and
uglier freedom of expression is given to
people who stand up for what they're
saying and not hiding behind anonymity I
actually basically think this is a
pretty good thing these message boards
and the comment sites and even what's
going on here on YouTube we'll get to
that in just a second has become a haven
for racists and anti women and
anti-semites and give me something else
anti-gay is homophobes thank you and all
kinds of just endless hate I do think
there's some reasons that this may be a
problematic because if you're in a
country that's not free and this is your
only form of expression that could be a
problem but let's just start with the
United States and the Western world in
the free countries is this basically a
good idea because all of this stuff it's
just crazy people ranting and raving and
you know a little something about
ranting and raving Jimmy or something
about I mean all you have to do is go to
youtube pick any video clip go to the
fourth comment and the fourth comments
are always viciously rips the third
comment there cuz the fourth comment
there's always a jerk what is it about
number for it so it's always starts with
three like things related to the video
and then by four and then the fifth guy
comes in and tries to find common ground
between everybody and for that the six
comments are impugns his sexuality so
that's pretty much how it goes um I
don't you know you kind of get you I I'm
one of those guys that I'll find myself
getting caught up like in Huffington
Post I'll make a comment and then
someone comments back I'm like you
little dick and then I'll say something
back before I know it like I'm in a
thing I'm like how did I get in this
okay so my policy on it is that I will
not even on Twitter if someone's just an
egg if they're just an anonymous egg
will not debate you I just yeah I can't
a debate an anonymous thing you know to
me but if you're a person I'll engage
I'll try to engage in some sort of level
of discussion if they are who they say
they are so the anonymity thing half the
time that people are like anonymous you
can have hi I'm bill green or whatever
and you don't know it's a fake picture a
fake person a you know and they could
start an account with another email so I
take that all with a grain of salt
anyways and people on Twitter that I
mean I just block them anyways I don't
even give them the time of day so it's
like I don't even I won't even go into a
debate with a troll who if they hate you
anyways and they're spewing hate and
they you know that they're not even
gonna reason or see your side and they
just hate you for whatever reason then
we move on yeah we've got we've got a
couple numbers to look at related to the
hate online commenters 35% of the
miranne animus and 61% use a pseudonym
as far as the anonymous commenters go
34% of them put out positive stuff 55%
put out neutral stuff 11% negative do
you think there's some importance to
having some level of anonymity though
because in the bigger world when people
need to express themselves somehow and
they can't because of governments not
that I mean we know our government's
watching us now too so what do you think
do I think it's important yeah III think
it's read first of all there are risk in
taking anonymity away from the internet
I think it you need to have anonymity
yes and I'll I will often um if I want
to make a comment I will often go under
a sword in him right or and so yeah I
will do that I think it's important and
you don't want anybody who gets offended
at internet comments you know needs it
needs to go back in and it slapped their
parents because they weren't raised
correctly right what's wrong with you
get up so you need to just lie I think
it's great actually yeah do you think
there's maybe some reason that all these
people that are walking around with so
much hate and so much racism and
homophobia and all that stuff you think
there's actually something positive the
fact that they get it out while sitting
at their computer as opposed to bottling
it up and then doing something crazy
really if people are bottling up their
anger and their hey I just look at
people that that that write nasty things
anonymously are trolls anyways who
have the balls to say it to my face and
you know half the time it's not even
things like they're afraid of their
government cracking down and then we're
talking about like people that are
anonymously bullying a girl in in their
school or something that's [ __ ] it's
like meet me on the playground
okay pal that's how we used to sell it
when I was a kid it's like there's none
of this Facebook [ __ ] there's none of
this I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna
start another Facebook page and you know
there's a small percentage of people
that are afraid - afraid of governments
may be afraid of workplace violence or
something that they're posting that they
feel like they need to get it out on a
comment section on a blog I mean really
that's the important part of this no
yeah and I was trying to make a
distinction between someone that lives
in a relatively free society and versus
there are places let's say in the Middle
East where maybe you need to be
anonymous on a message board so you can
argue against Syria and you're trying to
get information out and you're sneaking
it you're hiding in safe houses and
you're trying to get the truth out to
the world that's something completely
different but Jimmy do you have a
message for the commenters on this video
because they're gonna be very upset with
us no matter what my message for them is
that I think they they're they're all
very witty and snappy dressers
I think that you know what I didn't
think about that the kids being bullied
that's different for sure I agree with
her on that but I just want to say I
think like when you see like especially
YouTube people are so over the top
correct like they'll just be racist out
of nowhere or just completely I think
what I'm saying is I think it makes me
kind of laugh now so I think it helps
just kind of laugh that [ __ ] off so
those people don't get on nerds because
that's all they're doing that's what a
troll is right that's an interesting
point that they're sort of getting it
out and you can and it really shows it's
because it's typed and you can look at
it and read it again you can really see
how ridiculous and evil all this racism
and all down the rabbit hole I've done
that a couple times in the oldest said
next thing you know like a half an hour
later you're still looking at like this
chain of comments of people down here's
like you know someone so 0:07 you suck a
bubble you know and I'm like wait which
one what did he say again you're trying
to go back and find what he's coming
it's just it's not even worth my time
how insulted could I be at a guy with a
screen name
fart saber you know what I mean exactly
and on that note I think I can speak for
jimmy dore Ehnle and tweeted when i say
you guys are all wonderful we love you
and we have nothing but nice things two
things don't be and say about you you
anonymous wonderful people you okay
cory booker he is the mayor of newark
right now but he is the Democratic
nominee for Senator for New Jersey to
replace Frank Lautenberg who kicked the
bucket after he was like 177 years old
and he most likely will be the next
senator from New Jersey to come over on
the Mayflower fact right there from
Jimmy Dore that's right that was an old
that was a neat joke there you go that
was an old joke at an 18 so the thing is
with Cory Booker I did not know this but
apparently there are gay rumors around
him he's always been very proud he's
always been very Pro gay I actually
interviewed him once at at a gay event I
thought he was married and until I read
this story I thought he was married I
didn't get any I thought he was a great
guy I just got to say like he was a
great guy we actually talked about
basketball mostly but he did do that
interview on your lap right he was
sitting on my lap naked which but Eddie
who was Christmas he has addressed sort
of gay rumors this week and I think did
it in a really interesting way let's
take a look and people who think I'm gay
some part of me thinks it's wonderful
because I want to challenge people on
their homophobia
I love seeing on Twitter when someone
says I'm gay and I say so what does it
matter if I'm if I am so be it
I hope you were not voting for me
because you are making the presumption
that I'm straight there's a little bit
of sort of antithetical sort of
backwards speak logic in there but I
kind of think it's great yes I think
it's great and and you know what who
care really doesn't matter if he's gay
or not is not married I think I read in
our story that he said he went and and
seeked out a pastor or something and the
pastor's like he wanted some advice and
he goes get married and he's like wait a
minute that what I mean you don't have
to be married to be a mayor or a
or whatever sure maybe it looks kind of
weird because most men and at that age
and in that profession usually have a
family because they want to present the
family life or what everybody who cares
either way yeah I never said he's been
nothing been beyond the pro-gay and this
is a guy who runs into burning houses to
save families and when the hurricane
happened he had people staying at his
house and he's like moving you know
light fixtures that have fallen I mean
this guy he's a pretty good guy so I
look obviously now I'm pro game shoot
more than you guys like its sexuality
right should we just regard it's
irrelevant right I'm answering question
well you know as far as my voting goes
it's pretty irrelevant I think but it is
relevant in a sense like like he's a
politician he needs people to vote for
him like if Robertson that's why Kevin
Spacey still hasn't come out right
because it does affect the way people
vote for you it does effective ticket
sales so if Robert DeNiro came out as
gay would probably mess around with his
box office buddy even though I don't
think people hold it against him it just
there's a thing you want to be want to
like someone in a certain way yeah and
that's what I've you know I mean I
thought that he's gay it bothers you
more than that he's a middle-aged man
that's not married and doesn't have a
family no it doesn't bother me what
bothers me about cory booker is that
he's a tool of wall street I in fact I
think it's almost if he was gay would be
for me a positive because it would it
would mean that he has an a more open
mind about the way world works yeah so
that's for me but those people I don't
think would feel that way okay so if he
was a Republican and he had gone and had
a platform that was anti-gay or he was
against marriage equality or any that
stuff we all be against that right I
think I can speak close there but is
there something even more dangerous if
he is gay and again I'm not saying he is
I'm not even putting the rumor out that
at all but let's just say it was someone
of his stature that was gay but still
closeted and still Pro gay is there even
more danger in that in a weird way do
you think that that's possible I'd like
to ask the gay community that you know
does that bother you that somebody that
you think is potentially gay that is Pro
gay in his you know public political
standing
and and but he won't come out I mean
does that bug you I get a knock out
inquiry book right think he's straight I
met him I believe because it doesn't
matter to me if he's a good mayor if
he's a good senator then who cares I
mean it's his constituents in the end
that are gonna have to to vote and go we
like this guy he stood up for us he had
people in his house he runs into burning
but you know whatever it's like who
cares about a sexuality you know what I
mean it's like it can he run our
government give me 30 seconds on the
Wall Street stuff because I basically
like him but he is pretty close to Wall
Street and and it's been a lot of
problems so let's so let's bang them up
a little bit legitimately well if you're
like me and you think the biggest part
of our problem right now in our economy
is that the wall street's control of it
well then you'll think that cory booker
has probably got the worst flaw you can
have it as a candidate so that's what I
think like Wall Street's them and invest
their money right that's every
politician there's almost everybody no
you're right that's I mean that desk
that's why there's wolf pack and that's
why those people trying to get money out
of politics you're exactly right he's no
he's not unique in his no you're right
yeah
all right well whether you're gay or not
Booker let's let's ease up on the Wall
Street connection okay yeah a date that
I don't care if he's gay as long as he
has the strong shoulders in the bedroom
eyes which he's incredibly fit and you'd
like to wrestle with him wouldn't you
very handsome all right let's move on
there is a new app called Lou Lou and
this is where women girls are can
anonymously because we're talking about
anonymity on this show they can
anonymously rate and review their male
Facebook friends as well as men that
they don't know and again this is
completely anonymously let's look at
their mission statement Lulu is a
private network for girls to express and
share their opinions openly and honestly
we created Lulu to unleash the value of
Girl Talk and to empower girls to make
smarter decisions on topics ranging from
relationships to beauty and health but
basically what it is is just a ranking
system of dudes you upload the dude you
answer some questions about him and
and then girls can decide if they want
to hook up with him or have sex with him
or datum or just ignore him so are you
on there it's my first class no I'm a
married woman but again that's one of
those things where I'm thinking if
you're a woman and you need a nap to sit
there and choose who you're gonna sleep
with or who's cool or who's not and
again who's to say that it's a woman's
only app yeah who's to say that there's
not guys on there pretending to be women
just to go on there and troll and see
what they're see what the girls are
saying or to make good comments about
themselves I mean right guys you know I
mean so basically I think the people
that are using this app take it with a
grain of salt that it maybe it's more
entertainment than it is am I gonna
sleep with this guy does they have an
STD was he good to his ex-girlfriend
right I mean he's an ex for a reason so
let's find out what I mean it just it
just seems so stupid and kind of
frivolous to me but if college girls
want this and to check out a guy on
campus and then they think it's
legitimate enough that they can trust it
and believe it wouldn't what happens if
if a guy gets a great rating and then a
girl gets raped by him though is she
gonna sue lulu absolutely you know what
I mean there's so many things that you
can open up in that Pandora's Box that
are not good it's a huge Pandora's box
and the thing is that if you liked a guy
if you really liked a guy you'd probably
be with him right so if you don't like a
guy don't want barley just trash him on
this thing because you don't want it guy
I know a little something about girls
they don't like passing off the good
guys to other girls right don't they
want the girl isn't that the whole point
gimme unlike guys who like to pass the
best girl around all the time and if the
guy does go rape someone I'm and it's
gonna hurt his rating the point now I
think it's women I decided it's all
funny to me you know massive women you
don't need an app to get a guy you have
an app it's called the vagina yeah you
already have it called a brain it's
competing the guy in person somewhere
you know I mean I don't know it just
didn't get women but women don't eat
apps again men you have the app right
and is there something crazy to think of
that the bet girls would be helping each
other get good guys just seeing it
doesn't seem like the way of the world
sort of you know even if even if the
sexes were reversed so Mike
friends and I are not I don't know maybe
we're a little bit older than this the
the the 20-somethings in college now but
we would never go on a nap and be like
oh let's see what the other girls around
town are saying about the guy at the bar
I mean it's like really why what's the
point at the risk of us don't even know
that it really is true right exactly so
at the risk of us sounding like old
fogies here this table oh my god we're
so old compared to these kids with their
apps but is there are we losing a little
something like I've seen love letters
that my grandfather wrote to my
grandmother when he was away in the war
you mean are we losing actually some
level of romance and courtship with you
know knowing everything you can
immediately you can meet someone at a
barn for getting the app you can jump on
Facebook and suddenly find out
everything about them or I know I've
been in a relationship since the
Facebook was invented and so I don't
know what that's like and every once in
a while I'm reminded somebody will tell
me it's like oh I met this guy I didn't
even know his last name so I couldn't
look him up on Facebook it was so
exciting to get to know him
and I was just like that is such a weird
way to date now like you already know
somewhat [ __ ] about someone before you
ever have sex with them like you're
supposed to have sex and not know them
that's what makes it fun that's the
whole point of sex
can you imagine knowing about someone
that you're having sex takes out the fun
right so I don't know what it's like to
date like that I'm did you know what I
think this really is like a generational
thing that these Millennials or younger
that they just they just don't
everything is on their fan i watch
teenage girls text each other while
they're in the same room you're like
they'd rather text and do these little
like abbreviations and [ __ ] then talk to
one another I've heard of it I don't
even know what snapchat snapchat is
sorry excuse me that's an idea for an
app the evolution right if you have ever
seen they like to start the chart right
of the homo sapien so it starts out as a
caveman and rape and then now and then
you're operating now it's right now like
this
down it's like yes you're right it's
going back it's like people putting TVs
in their cars it's like I'd rather look
at a fictional representation of the
outside world but actually look at the
outside world there's a world happening
right as you go by it yeah I mean that's
the problem and you see people you know
it's like the girl that the famous girl
texting she walks into the into the the
waterfall or whatever in the mall and
she tried to sit them on like mall right
but it's like you're so kids I think if
the Millennials are so self-centered and
everything is about them and everything
is about like instant and they they want
it now and they want to communicate but
not real communication it's like this
faux communication they don't even think
they know how to have a conversation
with a man I mean so it's very
disturbing I'd really love to take a
selfie right now with you guys but they
took my phone away before we started the
show okay we got a perfect segue here
because let's keep talking social media
this one I think is completely bonkers a
school district in Glendale that's in
California not too far from here in Los
Angeles has hired a company to monitor
the social media posts made by a student
so this yeah that's right Jimmy this
company will be monitoring 13,000
students at 8:00 middle and high schools
we're talking about their Twitter
accounts their Facebook accounts I guess
snapchat and BK and if you read if you
continue on the story they're only
reading what's public so it's what's out
there it's what people are tweeting and
I mean you know the kids that killed the
Australian guy running you know they now
can go on that kids Twitter account and
he's talking about guns and they're
bored and killing people and so I mean
you can gather a lot of information
about what people do that doesn't bother
me if kids are gonna go out there and
put [ __ ] out there on the internet and
its public and it's open and a school
can go maybe I can stop a school
shooting or I can stop a kid that's
being bullied that may be suicidal and
talking about it cuz almost every child
that we've seen that has killed
themselves have posted they do post
these like this is it I just want to say
goodbye to everybody or whatever and you
might be able to save a child they said
they have saved somebody from from from
committing suicide and you know I didn't
bother me yeah
they're not going into private accounts
and doing all that stuff but they say
they're not so okay so they write they
say they're looking at the public stuff
and I'm with you on the sentiment of
that that they're gonna try to stop kids
from killing themselves or they can
watch out for bullying or that kind of
stuff
but isn't this really just another layer
of Big Brother watching you and we're so
we're put now it's becoming systemic to
kids in middle school so of course
they're gonna grow up and not care that
the NSA is watching them and all that
keeps something used to the nanny state
right away the surveillance state you're
used to no matter what you do the
government knows somebody's watching you
and in its time right now when we're
cutting but local school budgets and
firing teachers what a because there are
better use of arts resources than the
hires of [ __ ] that spy on kids
Facebook has no art or music I'd rather
spend forty thousand dollars monitoring
13,000 students that way than having ten
teachers that have molested children
that are still on payroll because of the
damn unions talking about budgets and
schools and good teachers we can go a
long way if the choices molesters or
this program I'll take this program but
I don't think that's necessary but let's
look at some numbers related to teens
and social media use ninety-one percent
of them post a photo of themselves
somewhere on social media 71% have their
school names probably on their Facebook
page 71% post the city or town where
they live fifty-three percent have their
email address up there and 20 percent
posted their cell phone number I'm 99
percent sure that's all Facebook and
that's that was a Pew Center study so
already we're putting all this stuff out
there so that goes to the thing of why
do they have to hire a company to watch
it considering it's already all out
there you know they're just taking their
students and then probably you know they
probably have keywords or things that
stand out that they can quickly go
through a program and pick out potential
problems you know versus just trying to
click on 13,000 Facebook pages of their
students you know there's some risk
though in that kids just do and say
stupid stuff and when we did and said
stupid stuff in junior high and in high
school that if it was off school grounds
and you weren't punching a kid on school
you did it and then it worked itself out
but now if you're a kid and you
host something stupid or some joke that
doesn't quite make sense the school is
going to be all over you and you're
gonna happen there was a girl who was
she tweeted something that the governor
came to their high school and she had
tweeted something about how you know
he's a douchebag or something and so the
principal called guy that girl got in
trouble for tweeting something about the
governor which i think is unbelievable
this is the trouble if the governor came
to school and she stood up and said
you're a douchebag to his face she
probably reprimanded you do that though
she'd be but she did do it at public
forum but you can't write an article
that's critical of the of the governor
of course you can this is the
interesting part this is the interesting
is it different if you were well first
off I think you're allowed I mean
legally you're allowed to call the
governor a douche bag if you want right
you know you still make it suspension or
you might get you know time after class
or something for disrespecting apology
or somebody coming to your school I mean
if you'd be disruptive to class or
whatever I mean you could potentially
still get in trouble right the
difference here is that in the old days
of man you know days you might have
watched the governor speak and then you
walk out of there and you say to your
friends this guy's a douche bag now you
tweet it and now that's where the danger
lies now and I will just say this is
happening in Glendale so where they're
trying to monitor the social media of
the kids in Glendale and if you notice
school districts are doing it too it's
not so because Glen day is full of
Armenians and they're very shifty so
it's maybe it's maybe not a bad idea
hey girl Ana Kasparian is right back you
know and she's one of the good she's
part of that five percent you don't hear
about exactly all right last topic let's
talk about the neo-nazis those crazy
wacky guys they're back they never go
away then we're gonna find out about
their Facebook page in a second this
this story is so bonkers it's ridiculous
a man living in North Dakota
his name's Craig Cobb he lives in the
town of Leith which is a huge town it
has 19 people he wants it to become an
all-white town a neo-nazi town where
they'll be free to do all their neo-nazi
box
yes completely now the thing is guess
how many black people currently live yes
yeah one you're right there's one guy so
basically they're trying to get the one
black guy out it obviously this is
completely insane he wants anyone who
lives on his property so on this town
that they'd be required to fly a racial
banner 24 hours a day such as a Nazi
flag they'd also be required to try to
import more responsibly radical hardcore
white nationalism Oh white people is
there anything I mean reading this story
and then reading that he had been buying
up these properties so he could expand
his property and then invite his white
friends hey come on you can come live on
my property amp is buying it up it's so
scary I mean I'm surprised that the one
black guy that lives in that town
actually made a comment at the end of
that story it's like well hopefully it's
not gonna hurt anybody you know I'm not
faking man and he's got balls too savvy
I wouldn't want to leave either and
that's my town it's not you know you're
trying to create something else that I
was here first it's where I live but
that's gonna be the only cool guy in
town can you imagine a town of just
white people uh sounds horrible yes I
can imagine it would be pretty boring
and imagine it yeah anyway but dance
clubs ever this guy by the way is such
an [ __ ] he got kicked out of Canada
basically for being an [ __ ] yeah
that's what gave me go to Europe first
and then you guys went back got kicked
out of Europe so he goes to Canada
Canada goes you're too big of an [ __ ]
to live here so you know he goes to
North Dakota where there's no one lives
there yeah so now we my Norwegian family
like all when they kind of migrated over
the United States took over the Dakotas
cuz they're like great it's like Norway
and nobody wants a Norwegian I probably
a lot of tweeting ZUP in the Dakotas but
it's funny that they took over that land
because it's cold and rocky and nobody
wants to live there and they're like
we'll take it what prize the other half
Filipino Oh in Spanish
yeah well they're not good they don't
want any Filipino there either I'm sure
you it was all the white Norwegians yeah
but playing devil's advocate here for
just a second is should we just allow
this to be because you know what if this
crazy white supremacist wants all his
white supremacist buddies to go live
with him over there maybe why get out of
her life he was able to buy a house for
$5,000 in this city yeah and all I can
think of this once this guy moves in
values are going down he doesn't want
any gay people living there but doesn't
he know that when gay people move next
door to you gentrification the whole
place yeah yeah but really should we
just like should we not even talk about
this in because let them if they want to
separate themselves and be very isolated
up there because I mean who really wants
to live in North Dakota I don't yeah
thank you so much I mean he's not
breaking any laws as of right now I mean
he's just trying to gather all his white
and neo-nazi friends to go live with
them and that whatever leave the the
crazy kook heads up there by themselves
how ironic had to come back to the
United States and multicultural
countries we can have his hate yeah and
the white countries they wouldn't allow
it so much even though Canada's a lot
more multicultural than we think but I
forgot my second point you had something
there there's something that will get
you around to it all right well I mean I
see this as sort of let let the guy have
his white I was just want to say it's
good we did so now we can be like
identified when I see you like a
skinhead like oh good I don't know I
know did not go near you you're not
gonna trick me I'm not gonna walk over
to you and say nice thing to you and you
go hey how about those [ __ ] you ever
have that have like all [ __ ] stop it I
didn't know that was coming so it's like
guys who wear the the American flag
looks like I I know you're an [ __ ]
already I don't need to meet you so
that's why it's good to see those people
you keeps them away from you yeah you
know we can thread all the stories we've
done here together because I'm pretty
sure some of the people that are moving
to North Dakota this guy are the
anonymous commenters we talked about
earlier there's white supremacy
Loeb anonymous comment table spew their
hate wherever they can find it for them
they absolutely will but we know you
guys won't and that's why we love you so
comment like that's Liane tweet and
that's Jimmy Dore I'm Dave Rubin we'll
do this again next week barring World
War three okay